ah yes
we got people out here biting I mean if
I had to rate my Jamaican accent I would
say I'm Elite
I mean what a dancehall
the islands all have in common
Drake
[Applause]
[Music]
so when you hear me speaking of Jamaican
accent Just go with it ah
I am the island bombing
really committing the color broken
hearts is better than whatever party
don't know it from the story till I'm
still dirty yet
see
dude
Cincy his face didn't change at all the
whole time unbelievable dude he didn't
hit notes with his countenance
unbelievable dude the guy does a
uh what is Patois what do they all have
in common Drake I'm the Drake I'm the
Jamaican Drake
calling me being beat up them things
Drake
connection I would say I'm Elite the guy
from the office if I have to rate my
Jamaican accent I would say I'm Elite
well what what
bombing I mean what a dance hall the
home of the crowd the islands all have
in common
Drake break up quick I call me shout out
uh
Scentsy do what he's doing with his left
hand could call me Shabba Ranks Drake
Drake Drake this is [ __ ] Chet Hanks
dude
you know this guy I need Kamoze you're
not even snow
big open
Informer you know said anyway
didn't think I knew that I know it
what's the [ __ ] Here Comes
still living like that how I know what
Bo don't know touch them up and go uh oh
dude touch them up
haha
Sensei so when you hear me speaking of
Jamaican accent Just go with it I mean
uh Just Go With It pleading
please just go with it you know I can be
drinking
bombing I am the island
like you move on to something else
dude dirtier
Sean uh what's his name
who's the
[ __ ] Jamaican guy Sean John no no
that's the clothing side thing is it
Sean who's the [ __ ] Jamaican guy
uh the one that goes
with that big [ __ ] with the beaker on
his [ __ ] thing he's a good looking
dude but the [ __ ] God damn it what's
his name let me I gotta look it up dude
this is the annoying part too because
Big Jim uh reggae artist because some of
you guys know who I'm talking about in
who I'm listening to
Sean Paul dude
John netball dude bro if your name's
Sean Paul don't say it like John Paul
you know
seven best reggae artists of all time
right here
I just can't with reggae man
um
every song
and then Bob Marley and then they'll be
like man it's crazy how political his
music is and then you'll be like oh
really play it we jamming like
ah we're German in the name of the law
not political jamming
with German
hey
not political oh yeah
so political because they will be on the
area word I'm up
15 greatest and most famous Reggae
singers of all time here you go here we
go bye
hellomusictheory.com run a lot of
websites
um here we go
someone can call me racist from for all
this for sure one Bob Marley great
obviously one of the most famous artists
of all time number two
Peter Tosh and that's how you know
that reggae
I mean who the [ __ ] is Peter Tosh am I
an idiot let's go to number three
Desmond Decker heard of that one
Gregory Isaacs heard of that one okay so
number two I didn't hear but Jimmy Cliff
never heard of him
have you I am feeling very Olympic today
well
um not not that uh Dennis Brown don't
know him
that was Cool Runnings yeah so racist
that they put that in the clip loving
no wow this is so Jamaican to make a
song and start it by saying love and
hate here's another one uh seven Burning
Spear
this is called
Rasta business dude it's one of my top
10 albums of all time and that's all
I've heard and that's all I know about
it I'll never hear any more of it dude
that is unbelievable dude oh yeah we
dumb and love on the hit
oh number eight dude is called toots
that's the band name dude Calvin could
be in that one huh
that's toots dude wow dude
[Music]
oh dude Toots and the May talls that's
what it's called dude I mean ah same
song
oh wow this one's the [ __ ] well I gotta
get into reggae music this guy's name is
Sizzla
oh dude was eating at a restaurant and
got his name so uh let's see this one
Sizzler I'm living
2015 it came out
this is the beginning of the thing it's
just wind
and fire crackling burning out
I can't wait to hear the beginning
[Music]
here's bunny Whaler
here we go
it's called liberation
[Music]
ah same band as all the other guys
we're really busy man we're really busy
we booked till
2075 man
every night and also matanese man
[Laughter]
and this guy is the guy who hits them
team drums man
it's us to rebook till 2000. ah we just
got a phone call we booked till 3023 man
foreign
and also
we also did all the songs in a Rasta
businessman
here we go Marcia Griffith Marsha
Griffiths
[Music]
it's very good dude leave it to the
chick to keep it real Ziggy Marley heard
of him let's do it
oh I love it wind again
sounds pretty different to me Janet K
okay a little bit still sounds like a
little bit like it Shaggy dude you know
number 14. shag he's always like this
[ __ ] sounds different
oh yeah no but the best was Shabba Ranks
we're Shabba Ranks Shabba Ranks nobody
was better than Shabba Ranks and of
course he's not even on this list dude
[ __ ] all that dude Shabba Ranks was the
[ __ ] dude how much is Shabba rank [ __ ]
nine women
[Laughter]
says [ __ ] nine women dude and he's
like 60.
and he's toward the world dude and he
only wears pants whenever he's around
him
[Music]
wow dude
um
wow dude that's unbelievable the
Jamaican the Jamaican uh Drake
congratulations
[Music]
[Music]